hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back but let's play good so
we got to go down to the basement to
discover some super secret ah a nice
well that's a novel weapon one don't you
think about that before all right
oh this looks nice yeah put prick your
finger on that what sort of answers
could be down here in the basement bad
one ah I think that's a don't on it so
that was a bad idea but I'm full of bad
right on top of it we OH
mother knows best under her guidance I
continued to delve deeper into my past
clues as to what I once was what I would
become must be contained somewhere in
our old apartment I had only just
started looking however however when I
was over overcome by another sudden loss
of consciousness as I struggled against
the UH navigable inevitable tide I felt
something in my mind slip just slightly
sorry I kind of [ __ ] flubbed up
reading oh no not a sewer level
it's pretty intense noise oh that's cuz
he was breaking Oh interesting what the
hell was back here it's nothing here oh
I mean it was cool but I thought I was
doing something I thought it was gonna
find a secret whatever fine whatever
what is this place good question oh my
head hurts
yeah more than that's gonna hurt in a
second what da fudge what the baloney oh
my nice breakdance oh yeah that sounds
about right
and off we go oh I got no ammo I'm gonna
died the first monster oh thanks well
that wasn't much at all that's not even
one monster hit it seems like I'm
playing this on hard because it's really
really intensely difficult very
punishing oh what a [ __ ] how Oh what
was that
oh my you don't know wiping up those
batteries oh and there's also the doors
in here but I don't
not sure which one to go through thank
you okay let me go see what's over here
nope nope nope nope nope nope
whole lot enough ah batteries the most
essential of all drop diet I need right
now
nope Oh Oh God stop doing that to me
Jamis I swear I'm gonna have a heart
attack before I get on this
freaky deaky wasn't it nothing in there
ah what's it then huh
what's all this secret right now
pronounce you try bad try that probably
very bad oh my gos bad
ah maybe it was a c-come row
I love me for my boom banger just
testing the walls making sure they're
certified and now I'm starting to wonder
what was the other way cuz you know
there was that other direction but on
hoozy or a max power or not what you
could not die with like 20 bullets in
your face god damn ah ha now you're dead
ah these things are tough I swear
floating Peter Pan douchebags
maybe I'm not breaking enough box it
seems like I've been breaking more boxes
oh thank you yes please oh yes oh man
maximum power
not going in there yeah not a bad cat ah
this probably means they're gonna hurt
me very very hard hurt me hard
yeah I wonder when that kid on the
little scooty board is gonna pop up out
of nowhere
probably oh look an elevator for two
floors
I fail got you though Oh found one of
Anita's dolls that's good for me was
hiding behind a pot with that oh it's
mac-10 ammo or whatever ah I knew it I
knew I knew it I knew that kid was
coming around I do it
hey all right I knew I knew it I knew it
I knew it's so much there was so much of
that that I knew that it was that gonna
be back ah god I'm gonna lose my voice
oh he's been screaming so much playing
this game I swear not
no I don't want to go in there a knife
yeah I already have a knife
it's very nice knife but I don't want
that one so simple just take the knife
and do it okay so I have a Oh what are
you oh my god getting out of your
[ __ ] screw you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you in
scream ah no no no no no die you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] there you couldn't see Oh PO
dodge yeah
god damn it ah ah what the [ __ ] alky
oh my flashlight we love whoa oh man I
don't even know what that was some guy
in a straitjacket oh my god
new chainsaw guy um oh whoa whoa whoa
hey hey easy up there buddy
I got the knife was the knife mean what
do I do with a knife I don't know I go
back I go back to the way that I did
come from that way that I was there to
use me thank you for being open now
there's nothing in here anyway Oh got ya
all right I think I go back now oh good
frigging scissors in your head but if
man they got so many different types of
enemies in this game it's redonkulous ah
no oh man I got switched to like though
rail or something okay
so there's nothing in here now I go down
here oh that seems normal
yeah seemed about right patient 3 1 1 3
6 3 I think this is something to do with
my father this record says something
happened to him at San Cross Hospital
whoa door suddenly door ok I'm going
what what the hell
Buzzard I'm going to refer number 3 1 1
3 6 3 2 a psychiatric examination in the
suzannecross hospital he must be secured
at all times because of his aggressive
behavior during examinations it is
suggested that he should locked that he
should be locked in one of our special
patient care rooms
patient was arrested for a brutal murder
in November the police have requested a
psychiatric examination I have to find
my father's records right cuz suddenly
that's an objective anything else in
here no car ah on the road again ha boom
Biba dabba doo boo was throw it again
live it up a DVD Villa road again
cut down some on the bottom there ooh
pretty
not really
finally a concrete crew clue has
surfaced my father who was so rarely a
topic of discussion between myself and
mother as researched in the form of a ha
in the form of a hospital documents my
path became clear for the first time in
what seems like years I made my way
quickly to the hospital in search of
records of files on my father or other
family members who might have been
admitted the family history has become
of the utmost importance to me why cuz
you're all crazy
even your mama your mama so crazy she
married your dad Danna God wrong with me
they must be in here somewhere
you don't even know that you're in the
hospital you stupid nope nope nope nope
nope where ah gotcha
okay Kimmy fly all you want ow fudge was
that ah what the hell oh just kill my
whole health bar my whole health of are
just gone like that good matter I hear
ya yeah I just I'll be with you just a
second here we go
I'm in uh here we go ha ha no I got you
Naga gotcha
you're such a loser you can't even
survive a drill to the face
no items just these stupid batteries it
must be for hard mode like hard mode has
a battery thing because in this one I
see nothing about that that Oh speech
bubble hi why
What did he say if you're gonna be real
there's it's a distraction so that they
can stab me in the butt hole knife up my
butt and it is usable
first a yes tea thank you and I'm all
out of time I'm sorry for like being so
suck at this game I tried to be good and
stuff but just work anyway I'll try to
be better in the next few games so thank
you all so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
but I